turn around mr. two things are gonna  happen first that phone over there it's  gonna ring second you're gonna be  wearing these cuffs who the hell are you  I'm the guy you didn't count on jack  reacher Purple Heart Silver Star you're  a legend there is this dent and the dust  people say you made it with someone's  head I need your help  they killed my mini men that used to be  under your command I know what you have  done for  suta stayed out of this followed man  here that was a mistake  really fellas  why do I get the feeling that you're  enjoying this  a very interesting way of saying thank  you  sorry he's not feeling you might want to  sister  how much does read your no how's it  going I won't be followed you think  you're invulnerable